et comparé aux autres émissions où ils
prennent des gens toujours connu on voit
toujours les mêmes voilà c'est pas
excitant la sas on peut pas pour moi on
peut pas s'en lasser à l'impossible ya
un koh lanta all star est ce qu on
pourrait vous appelez pascal pour un koh
lanta all stars ont pas du tout ce que
vous avez
pour moi on peut pas m'appeler pour les
super raison c'est que je suis
black-listé puisque j'ai fait de la télé
réalité ce que je ne regrette pas du
tout ensuite parce que vous avez fait en
télé réalité j'ai fait les anges
exactement voilà ce que je regarde pas
c'est un très bon mois une belle
expérience j'aurais également nature a
conclu marc disque dur donc si c'était à
refaire voilà ça vous est valorisé par
la production de men tous ceux qui font
de la télé réalité mais bon on le sait à
l'avancé on nous dit attention vous
partez faire latérite et ses films finit
donc vous y allez après faut pas le
regretter
d'accord ensuite je suis black je suis
black-listé parce que j'ai eu des gros
problème est que la production sas et à
cesser d'avancer de ces communs à tout
le monde le sait voilà donc déjà après
lorient problème quel genre de problème
mais sur les montages d'image on le sait
que sur chaque saison c'est de pire en
pire de toute façon c'est à 10 et les
montages images c'est à dire que là-bas
vous faites des situations et dans le
montage d'image c'est pas du tout les
mêmes situations vous fait passer alors
vous aimez remarquer chaque saison vous
avez le gentil le méchant il ya toujours
un mais ça c'est normal
oui c'est comme ici ça dit tu avais dit
ouais mais ça c'est de la télé tu fais
de la télé mais on ne sait pas nous
quand on fait koh lanta quand on va
faire koh lanta lé la télé c'est pas
notre notre fonds de commerce
on arrive et on nous voit à la télé on
voit un conseil mais c'est pas ça je
passe pour un pot pour un gros con ça
fait mal a commenté
on peut vraiment changer la personnalité
complètement oui enfin il faudra combler
vos téléspectateurs ses nombreuses
histoires et quant à pascal c'est normal
que chacun ait un rôle il faut habiter
la dir voix claire du storytelling
aujourd'hui si vous regardez besoin
qu'un canadien celui qu'on aime bien ya
celui qui est sexy et celui de koh lanta
d'avant ça a changé depuis que des mots
ni une émission ya celui qu'on aime bien
bah oui c'est que s'ils n'ont mené aucun
des deux
vu l'arrivée avec sa large ou bears a
complètement changé complètement
c'est comme les divisions n'ont pas
relevé
et puis 6 millions en france mais des
collants talent téléspectateurs sur le
joueur que de koh lanta qu'est fans de
l'aventuré ils regardent la télé diaz
vallée sur un jeu veut crever de faim je
veux bien mais il pour lui
koh lanta n'était pas n'est pas collé à
la télé réalité
certes on est en plein dedans mais non
mais dans la tête d'ailleurs on disait à
nantes a fait koh lanta va pas les ans
je te fais pas la terre a été tapée koh
lanta mais c'est de la télé réalité
mais qu'entend faire koh lanta on
s'attend pas à ces changement d'image
non je suis pas d'accord mais